considera las siguientes dos fracciones
un cuarto y cinco sextos reescribe estas
fracciones tal que tengan el mismo
denominador y numeradores enteros qué
números puedes usar para el denominador
las fracciones con las que vamos a
trabajar son estas un cuarto y cinco
sextos queremos escribir estas sus
fracciones tal que tengan denominadores
que coincidan ahora en el denominador
tenemos 4 y 6 entonces podríamos decir
bueno para que tengan el mismo numerador
podríamos poner cualquier número por
ejemplo 5 eso se puede hacer no no
podemos hacer eso la respuesta es no el
numerador adecuado debe ser un múltiplo
de 4 y 6 no podemos elegir un número al
azar así que debe ser un múltiplo de 4 y
6 un múltiplo de un número es un número
natural que lo contiene un número entero
de veces entonces veamos un ejemplo para
de entender esto algunos múltiplos de 4
serían 4 x 1
eso es 4 4 por 2 6 8 4 por 3 es
y así sucesivamente estos son múltiplos
de 4 ahora porque se nos pide un
múltiplo común entre 4 y 6 porque no
podemos elegir cualquier número sino que
tiene que ser un múltiplo de ambos
denominadores por qué pasa eso vamos a
analizar primero en un cuarto aquí
tenemos un entero dividido en cuatro
partes es decir en cuartos para
simbolizar un cuarto de este entero
vamos a colorear una de las cuartas
partes del entero ahora tal vez tú digas
bueno yo quiero colorear dos de las
cuartas partes yo quiero al dos como mi
numerador para tener un numerador de 2
tendrá que partir esta cuarta parte en
dos pedazos iguales y ahora tengo dos
partes sombreadas ajá entonces bueno
puedo decir que esto es igual a 2 de 1 2
3 4 o 5 partes no no esto no es dos
quintos porque porque estas partes no
son de igual medida si yo parto este
cuarto en mitad
debo partir todos los cuartos por la
mitad también
entonces bueno yo al hacer eso voy a
doblar las cantidades de pedazos que
tengo así que parto cada cuarto en dos y
así tendré pedazos de igual tamaño y
ahora lo que tenemos son 12 pedazos de 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 pedazos de igual tamaño
es decir 2 octavos y puedes ver que 8 es
múltiplo de 4 por que multiplicamos cada
cuarto en 2 ajá y eso es justo lo que
hicimos multiplicamos cada uno de los
cuatro pedazos que teníamos en dos
partes y también multiplicamos al
numerador por 2 es decir también lo
duplicamos así como al denominador a la
hora de duplicar la cantidad de pedazos
sombreados también estamos duplicando la
cantidad total de pedazos ahora bien no
sólo multiplicando por 2 funciona
podrías por ejemplo
multiplicar por 3 aquí tengo nuevamente
el entero dividido en cuartos de un
entero entonces sombre a una cuarta
parte y divido ese cuarto en tres
pedazos iguales obteniendo así un
numerador de 3
muy bien entonces de esta forma tenemos
un numerador de 3 pero aún no podemos
poner el denominador porque no hemos
dividido en pedazos iguales a todas las
cuartas partes restantes de este entero
entonces hagamos eso ya tenemos que
dividir si dividimos una de las cuartas
partes tenemos que hacerlo a las otras
cuartas partes así que lo hago quiero
que cada cuarta parte esté formado por
tres partes de igual tamaño entonces
vivido cada cuarta parte en tres pedazos
iguales estamos triplicando la cantidad
de pedazos y ahora puedes ver que
tenemos tres partes sombreadas de un
total de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
tenemos entonces tres pedazos sombreados
de un total de 12 pedazos y de hecho
podría ellos saber esto sin contar
porque si que estamos triplicando a cada
uno de los cuartos esta vez estamos
multiplicando a nuestro denominador
original por 3
triplicamos es decir multiplicamos tanto
al numerador como al d
dominador por tres así que los múltiplos
son ocho o doce etcétera y por lo tanto
los denominadores que podemos elegir son
exactamente esos un número por el que
podemos multiplicar nuestro denominador
y así multiplicar la cantidad de piezas
totales o de pedazos totales a bueno lo
voy a repetir para que quede más claro
tenemos aquí un cuarto dos octavos 3 o
sea 2 estos representan la misma
cantidad aquí tenemos el original que es
un cuarto aquí tenemos dos octavos y
aquí 3 doceavos todos estos números son
equivalentes todas estas fracciones son
equivalentes todos representan la misma
cantidad solo son diferentes maneras de
escribir el mismo número entonces bueno
vamos a regresar a nuestra pregunta
original que no me los puedes usar en el
denominador para un cuarto y cinco
sextos bueno sabemos que necesitamos
múltiplos de 4 y 6 así que vamos a
analizar los múltiplos de estos dos
denominadores iniciamos con el 4 cuáles
son sus múltiplos cuáles son los
múltiplos del 4
los primeros múltiplos del 4 son veamos
cuatro por uno de esos cuatro el segundo
múltiplo de cuatro es ocho porque dos
por cuatro es ocho lo cual nos dice que
a cada cuarto lo podemos partir a la
mitad y así obtenemos ocho pedazos el
tercer múltiplo es 12 pues 4 por 3 es 12
es decir si a cada cuarto lo partimos en
tres pedazos iguales obtenemos un total
de 12 pedazos el cuarto múltiplo 4 x 4
es 16 4 por 5 es 20 4 por 6 es 24 y así
bueno así podemos seguir la razón por la
que me detengo en 24 es porque
observando las opciones que tenemos en
las respuestas vemos que la posible
respuesta de mayor cantidad es 24 por lo
tanto ya no necesito escribir múltiplos
de 4 más grandes que el 24 ahora aclaró
que hay muchísimos más múltiplos de 4 de
hecho son infinitos los múltiplos de 4 y
de cualquier número pero
es necesario instar los todos tampoco
podríamos hacerlos porque son muchísimos
pero bueno aquí las respuestas el número
más grande considerar es el 24 así que
ahí ahí nos quedamos ahora vamos a
escribir los primeros múltiplos de 6
6 x 16 es decir si yo divido algo en
seis pedazos iguales lo dejamos
exactamente igual se quedan seis piezas
o podemos duplicar los seis pedazos es
decir a cada pedazo lo voy a dividir en
dos y así tendríamos dos por seis eso es
12 12 pedazos
seguimos 6 por 13 18 6 por 4 es 24
estaríamos dividiendo cada uno de los 6
pedazos en cuatro pedazos iguales y así
podríamos continuar enlistando los
múltiplos de 6 pero nuevamente nos
detenemos en 24 porque es el mayor
número a considerar como posible
respuesta entonces qué números podríamos
usar en ambos denominadores bueno
podríamos usar el 8 observa las listas
de los múltiplos de 4 y 6 8 es múltiplo
de 4 es decir podríamos dividir al 4 en
octavos
pero 8 no es múltiplo de 6 no podemos
dividir un sexto en octavos por lo tanto
el 8 no funciona como denominador común
de ambas fracciones ahora vamos a
analizar al 12 2 es múltiplo de 4 y de
hecho fue uno de los casos que dibujamos
el 12 es también múltiplo de 6 si a cada
sexta parte lo dividimos en 2
obtendríamos 12 pedazos iguales y así
tendríamos 12 a 2 por lo tanto el 12 si
es denominador común para un cuarto y un
sexto ahora vamos con el 18 el 18 es
múltiplo de 6 ajá por lo que podemos
dividir cada sexto en tres partes
iguales y obtendríamos 18 pedazos
entonces el 18 es múltiplo de 6 pero
observa que el 18 no es múltiplo de 4 18
no es múltiplo común de 4 y 6 y por lo
tanto no es denominador común de un
cuarto y un sexto así que el 18 queda
descartado y bueno finalmente el 24 éste
sigue es un común denominador para el un
cuarto y un sexto así que podríamos usar
ya sea el 12 o el 24
como denominador común y de hecho bueno
hay muchísimos múltiplos comunes entre
el 4 y el 6
pero de las opciones que aquí se nos
están dando el 12 y el 24 son los que
pueden ser utilizados como denominadores
para cuartos y sextos ahora como
información extra a muchas personas les
gusta utilizar el mínimo común múltiplo
que en este caso es el 12 y eso es
favorable hacerlo porque bueno facilita
a la hora de los cálculos ajá siempre
hacer cálculos con números pequeños es
mucho más fácil que con números gigantes
entonces bueno ahora si tú quieres
utilizar un múltiplo común que no sea el
12 1 mayor al 12 bueno puedes hacerlo no
no pasa nada entonces bueno puedes usar
el 12 o el 24 o cualquier otro múltiplo
común que le siga a estos pero bueno
como dije el 12 es el mínimo común
múltiplo y el más sencillo para trabajar
a la hora de hacer cálculos entonces
bueno en fin la respuesta a qué números
podríamos utilizar como denominadores
para cuartos y sextos
pues el 12 y el 24